to protect black birthing people
continue to fail
black birthing people enhance coverage
and support for birthing people
birthing people if this makes any sense
to you it's because you're a
so they finally came out with this
yesterday just in time for mother's day
so mom's everywhere you should feel
really flattered you may not be a woman
you're just a birthing person and the
same people who wear handmaids tales
outfits to to protest republican
abortion policy because they say
republicans keep reducing us to our
reproductive organs they keep reducing
us down to our reproductive abilities
call
women birthing persons now that's what
they call them
and it wasn't just one congress person
this is going to be the term
within within the next several months
you're going to see democrats adopting
this term in widespread fashion so
corey bush the adjunct member of the
squad she just joined from missouri
she's a former black lives matter
activist
i mean she's actually still a black
lives matter activist she's just in
congress now
she's talking about how birthing persons
are dying
now to you the normal human being who
like
all humans like like all homo sapiens
for the last 300 000 years or so
i've understood that birthing persons
are female you may say to yourself why
are we
now conveying less information why why
are we trying to obscure information
that is clearly obvious
that why don't you say moms instead
you a mother are now a birthing person
according to corey bush
every day black women are subjected to
hearthstone harsh and racist treatment
during pregnancy and child birth
every day black women die because the
system denies our humanity
it denies us patient care i sit before
you today
as a single mom as a nurse as an
activist and as a congresswoman
and i am committed to doing the absolute
most to protect black mothers
to protect black babies to protect
black birthing people and to save lives
okay black birthing people okay then she
tweeted out every day black birthing
people and our babies die so she used
mothers there like 10 times and women
so she fully understands that birthing
people are mothers and are women
right she totally gets it but instead
what she tweets is every day black
birthing people
and our babies die and this is the new
term right the new term is
birthing people now again i can't think
of much more degrading to a woman
than to suggest number one that the
process of pregnancy and childbearing
has nothing to do with being a woman
and simultaneously to suggest that you
can be boiled down to just bearing
babies like it is the exact opposite of
what feminism suggested feminism
suggested that women
are different than men and women ought
to be respected for that
and treated equally despite that
difference and in fact because of that
difference right feminism suggested
there's something special about being a
woman
the new feminism is there's nothing
special about being a woman and in fact
men can give birth
all of which is just ridiculous now i've
watched my wife give birth three times
it turns out it's a very female thing
it's a pretty amazing thing it's a
superpower that women hold and she's a
great
womanhood down to nothing is really
incredible
we've been told by the feminist left of
today that the highest achievement that
a woman can have
is to never have kids apparently and to
just spend your time working 2 200 hours
at a law firm so you can have a partner
title the same as a man
and delay child bear delay child bearing
delay child rearing delay marriage
this is the best move that you can make
if you finally do have a baby you should
you should
you know probably freeze your eggs and
then do it much later so you can have
your career development
you don't need a man to do any of this
sort of stuff now the the amazing thing
about this
is that the people who then end up
getting married and having kids are the
people who promote the same ideology
and the members of the new ruling class
is the point that charles murray makes
in coming apart the people
who are higher on the economic totem
pole
those folks tend to get married and have
kids it's just all the stuff they preach
filters into the culture
and it undermines marriage and it
undermines child bearing under healthy
circumstances
and it's really stupid okay but this is
something that the left has been pushing
for a long time and now it's come to its
culmination in
desexing having children right now it is
it is a sexless thing
to have children which is an amazing
amazing thing and again it was not just
corey bush representative carolyn
maloney from new york
she says the same thing america's health
system is failing
black birthing people how does one of
the most
medically advanced nations in the world
continue to fail
black birthing people at such high
rates to understand we have to take the
blinders
off our history and acknowledge that our
health care system
including reproductive health care was
built on a legacy
of systemic racism okay in a second i'm
going to talk about the systemic racism
point but the fact that you just keep
saying black birthing you mean black
women
why are you being so disrespectful to
women i honestly don't understand how
women could look at this stuff and not
feel insulted
it's ridiculous it's just it
it's it's beyond crazy but we're all
supposed to believe it
right and if you if you notice this they
get mad if you notice it's like why are
you even noticing
this i'm noticing it because you guys
are radically redefining biology you're
radically redefining reality in front of
me and i'm supposed to just be there
like
who cares representative
robin kelly from illinois she says the
exact same thing during the same hearing
so
obviously the memo went around it's no
longer black women it is black birthing
people
the federal government should support
access to
and the provision of patient-centered
data-driven quality maternal care
enhanced coverage and support for
birthing people during the postpartum
period
and address social determinants of
health including struggles they're
looking at their notes by the way you
can stop it there the the fact that they
keep using the term birthing people the
memo went around
don't don't defend people of the left
you have to virtue signal about the idea
that men could be women
so just to get this straight according
to the left here's how human biology
works you ready for this
according to the left birthing people
gestate meaningless clusters of cells
and then
those clusters of cells exit the
birthing people and they are assigned
sex at birth they don't have a sex
they're assigned it
by a doctor the doctor just looks at
them and randomly and then just assigns
sex at birth and then later
they decide their own sex if this makes
any sense to you it's cause you're a
honest to god if this makes any sense to
you it's because you have been
so well educated in the new woke
vocabulary at
major american universities that you've
lost your mind
it it is denial of fundamental human
reality it is denial of biology and it
does have consequences
the consequences some of them are
smaller and some of them are larger
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic
i'd watch that make it happen gang